on prime crime how do you pick the ones
that you think you're going to kill
the story of one of america's most
infamous murderers
because he did this same mo over and
over again he got
very good at it his own words on the
killings
did you have any conversation with her
my mind was on
killing her and hear from the people who
sat across
from evil i'll never in my life ever
interview
another killer like that in my career
plucked me another grief
i mean y'all got on to find him
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile
and memorable true crime cases our next
story is about a killer so renowned
we had to dedicate two shows to this
case
here is part one
in 1970 a woman is strangled to death
and buried in a shallow grave out in
florida
from there for the next 35 years bodies
would be found across different states
no connection no prime suspect
it would take decades before these cases
would be solved
and finally connected to one man
she was pretty a light skinned brown
honey colored can
this is samuel little also known as
samuel mcdowell
i met in a
nightclub in new orleans so i cut off i
took off
the exit went and that's sure enough
it was a road leading into the woods
and we went in and parked he may not
look like much when investigators began
interviewing him in 2018
in his late 70s and suffering from
health conditions
but the man you're seeing was the most
prolific serial killer
in united states history i grabbed
my legs and pulled to the
water that's the only one that i ever
killed by drumming that's just one
confession of many that little provided
to authorities after his capture at the
then
age of 71. i'll never in my life ever
interview another killer like that in my
career you know you first see him he's
this little old man in a wheelchair
that will remind me of a little man on
the porch
rocking in a chair telling you his story
was about his life
although his stories were demented north
little rock
tell me what that girl looked like oh
man i loved her
she was a heavy set big old yellow girl
and had buck teeth he had a gap twin
teeth that way but
she's too big for me to carry a
character so i just pulled out a car
laid on that
trash that was lit there there was no
remorse
whatsoever it was a matter of fact i got
him to kill
he went into great detail in his crimes
oh the only thing i
know is that i yeah and that was your
intent
sam little ultimately confessed to 93
murders from 1970 to 2005.
that's more than ted bundy the zodiac
killer and the golden state killer
combined we know of at least 93
women who were murdered he was not going
to stop
he actually told police that he found it
sexually satisfying to rape and kill
women
in order to really understand sam
little's reign of terror
let's first dig into the killings
themselves like many serial killers
sam little had an mo did you ever shoot
any of these girls shoot yeah with a gun
so everything was done by manual
strangulation did you ever use like a
belt or a cloth or no carrots
no ligatures at all my hands just your
hands and without that i wouldn't
want to do it he would take his hands
and he would
put him on their throats and he would
choke them and sometimes he would allow
them
to revive so he could
see the fear in their eyes before
choking around finally i was squeezing
hard enough for
the breath we couldn't be cut off and
sooner or later she kind of started
wanting to catch a breath and that's
when she tried to pull my hands off
it was too late man was it exciting to
you at the time
yes he was he's a sadistic killer for
sure
he wanted to feel like their neck
swallowing and i think his foreplay
basically he would take a lot of them to
eat
and they would go eat and swallow and
drink and i think that was his foreplay
that's what got him
excited was watching that neck so how
was it that little was able to commit
dozens of rapes and murders
without getting caught the reason sam
little went undetected for so many years
is because
of who he targeted primarily drug
addicted women
and sex workers he didn't know who the
hell to do anything
i don't go back to the same city
sometimes plucked me another great
[Music]
so basically these were women nobody
would miss he knew
which women would be not cared about he
knew which women would
not be missed he knew which women
would be susceptible to his advances
either whether they're romantic or he
was
providing them drugs or providing them
alcohol
she was oh yeah she's old
she was trying to make some money now he
knew which women on the lower levels of
our society
he could actually lure into his car
to take to a secluded place to quickly
kill them
in the dead of night where nobody could
see him
and then to dump their body immediately
and get out of dodge this is how he got
away with it
and i'm not just saying he said
no one you didn't get in
there with the people that would be
immediately
missed yeah and very
important to either family or business
or somebody
yeah you got pretty good at knowing
which ones level i'm not going to go
over in the white neighborhood pick like
a little uh
young teenage girl or like the ladies do
you and that's how little got away with
it over and over again
and because he did this secret because
he did
this same mo over and over again he got
very good at it coming up little had
spent his life
in and out of prison and had almost been
captured before
so what happened i've been lucky on a
numerous times
i wanted to be the vaccine with conceal
so she was already dead in the car
yeah okay after samuel little is
arrested in 2012 on a narcotics charge
investigators realize he's actually
responsible
for several cold case killings little
would ultimately confess
to 93 murders prior to his capture
though
little was a man who had been arrested
almost a hundred times
and only spent a total of 10 years
behind bars
so how is he not connected to these
crimes sooner and more importantly
how is he still on the streets for all
this time
i was looking for him i had a dead body
in the car joked out
yesterday i'm getting ready but
blue lights everywhere police cars come
back behind the building
he's seen this i jumped out of the car
and tried to act like a zipper on my
pants
he's look what all the photos what's
going on with us ain't nothing doesn't
mean my wife just coming in of course
pushing that down look in that window
with a flashlight let me tell you again
and i got away like that he said well
you gotta get out of him wow i got in
the car and took off
the police weren't able to put together
a strong case against him
because he himself knew how to get away
without leaving a lot of evidence i
never
cut stamp burn
bit but no none of that no blood i don't
like blood
he would initially strike his victims in
the head
and then strangle them and i think
ultimately when you think about this
you're not going to have any forensic
evidence later the bodies have
deteriorated so there were no markings
there were no
you couldn't see knife wounds to bones
you could not see
gunshot bullets there was no fractures
in these bodies
i was writing about pig farmers oh wow
and that's how the girl they found a
girl that landed steel next to thick
form
all of them again
sam little would dispose of bodies in
the everglades he would roll them down
hills he would put them in
densely forested areas he would let
parsley conceal
by vegetation left for layer
dna didn't really start being utilized
until the mid-1990s so
he was able to to get away with
any type of sexual crimes alabama did
the same thing
he had this black chick up in the car
and uh
nobody ran the plate or anything like
that no so they didn't put that on
he didn't run a plate nobody no he
wasn't looking for them
they found a body man about a month
later
even though he had 100 arrests and
served only
10 years prison time i would blame
partially the criminal justice system
because a lot of the cases against him
were dismissed
they weren't followed up with and he was
fleeing constantly he was very transient
and leaving to different
areas cities across the nation little
had had close calls before
but nothing may have come as close as to
when he was directly tied to
two brutal murders you know we caught
him
we believed he was responsible for
melinda luther's murder in 1982
and we know absolutely he was
responsible for patricia mount's case
now when you're driving around with
patricia mount in the front passenger
seat
did you have any conversation with her
my mind was on
killing her she let me fill her throat
you know caressing it
and before i knew it i uh tightened my
hands around it
after patricia mount's nude body was
found in that hayfield
hair fibers and witness testimony linked
little to the killing
and he went on trial yet once again
it was little's lucky day the jury found
him
not guilty as for melinda lapre a grand
jury
opted not to indict him other media has
come to us saying you know
if y'all had just tried him and he was
in jail all these people would be alive
and i will tell you that melinda lupree
had been out in the elements for over
three weeks
um and if you saw a picture of of her
remains you would understand there were
no evidence there to gain there were so
many
things so many times that uh he was
arrested for
for assaulting women and the women were
ladies of the night they were on drugs
those don't make the best witnesses
unfortunately a combination of lack of
hard evidence
issues with witnesses and little's own
ways of covering up his crimes
resulted in weak cases and him
continually striking plea deals
for shorter prison stints jillian lauren
a new york times best-selling author
and someone who spent hours interviewing
sam little has made it her mission
to be the voice of these victims because
of the fact that they were
often prostitutes often drug addicts
often women of color
um women who are considered unimportant
or as some cops
used to talk about the women who were
turning up in south central dead
almost every morning in the 80s um
nhi no humans involved but you know it
wasn't just
cops he was tried by a jury of his peers
once again it's us who let him go
up next little's crime spree comes to an
end
but his story is just beginning
i had desired strong desire
to kill her
and she played with you a little bit on
the way out there and
you killed her in the car yes i was
trying for it
he beat it too
samuel little who's come to be known as
the most prolific serial killer in
united states history
and whose crime spree spanned from 1970
to 2005
was able to elude justice for years that
is
until 2012. prosecutors and the police
were never able to actually pin a case
on it
until he left his dna californian
actually had a case where they had
run dna on a cold case and they had an
identical case or one that was a
similar mo and when they tested that dna
the dna came back to
a identical person in sam wool in
september 2012
little was arrested in a homeless
shelter in kentucky on an outstanding
california drug
charge when he was extradited back to la
investigators such as detective mitzi
roberts
were able to link little's dna to
material left at crime scenes in the
1980s
i was already putting together a san
locate because i was working all the
cold cases here
in my area in mississippi los angeles
mitch roberts called
asking do we have anything about assam
located so she came down
interviewed our witnesses to put
together a
method an mo of of the killer sam little
he fit everything with their cases
[Music]
in 2014 little was convicted of the
murders of three of his victims
carol alford audrey nelson and guadalupe
apodaca
but in a way little was also answering
for all the women
he had killed they were human beings and
that they were all
totally different they're you
in september 2014 little was sentenced
to three consecutive life terms in
prison
without the possibility of parole while
little had maintained his innocence his
whole life
in 2018 he finally decided to open up to
investigators
it's so good to meet you and i'd like to
personally thank you
for being generous enough with your time
i hope that clear up
when somebody is incarcerated and they
know they're spending their life in jail
their communication with the outside
world is
in essence gone you're so valuable to
society at this point i think
something to these people i thought was
a worthless thing to him
that i'm worth something he opened up
because it was his exit strategy
this was again part of his overall plan
this guy definitely was ready to talk as
soon as he knew
he wasn't going to be receiving the
death title that's the letter that you
requested
that our state attorney will not pursue
the death penalty under any
circumstances
now the question became how do you get
little to open up
i'd love to talk to you about
gainesville a little bit you know that's
that's where i live and work
i'm not i'm not a data fan i'll tell you
right now
you must be ohio state right you know
what urban did for our gators though
yeah now you were a usc fan too or
no no no but i can't stand california
yes but you lived out in california for
a while i
believed that several times going to be
little's interview for sure
i wanted to make sure that myself as a
prosecutor
was uh going to be somebody that he
wouldn't mind talking to
we knew that he liked the cleveland
browns
he's from the cleveland area we're from
and so that kind of uh
was our cash if you will to be able to
build this rapport with him what do you
remember about her
i told him
how i did it i talked to him straight i
told him his big perv
i told him i didn't agree with him he
would say would you call me a perverted
homicidal maniac
and i said well that's like certainly
one of the things i'd call you
and he was just like whatever you're a
hoe i was
mostly kind of honest with him coming up
little may have confessed to numerous
murders
but how do we know if he was telling the
truth
more when we return
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father guilty
or not guilty guilty think again
judge caprio rules with common sense i
was having contractions i was rushing to
the hospital inspector quinn what does
justice demand
jail and compassion i'm going to take
the
circumstances into consideration the
best court experience i've had
clearly judge he's been in a court
before get caught
in providence
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
welcome to prime crime tonight another
day of drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law on crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this is law and
crime
the only thing i did with one was kind
of
some live or someone didn't after serial
killer samuel little was finally
caught in 2012 and convicted of
murdering three women back in the 1980s
he decided to confess to more of his
crimes from 1970 to 2005
and that's when the floodgates opened
she also talked about a young lady
that you dumped down a stairwell yeah
that was a white girl yeah she was white
got her out of the car pulled up
and drunk her into
groups back then little ended up
confessing to killing 93 people
and would ultimately plead guilty to
several more murders
how do we know though that little was
actually telling the truth
i absolutely believe in his credibility
of the stories that he told he knew
everything about my crime in 1982
and then the 1977 remains actually
had a wig on nobody knew that but the
anthropologist and us
and he talks about she had a wig and he
threw it out the window if he killed our
our very first victim
one other case he was able to tell what
the
last item that a lady had eaten
was basically the carrots out of the
salad
and brown coffee and the autopsy report
shows undigested carrots and brown
coffee and that also goes from the 70s
it would have been dark fuse i don't
know how these pictures can really help
you
no i don't that must be blanket
yes how did you remember that
was also important what little said he
didn't do
we were all sitting around talking and
the detective says yeah you know
he killed mine he drew a picture of her
and i said what year was yours
he said 1998 i said no one understand
look
i said he was not out in 1998 so when
they go into the interview road and this
detective is starting to talk to him
about that case and i'm thinking
kelly if sam little confesses to killing
this one that's going to throw this
whole story in in the
in the break i mean it just none of it's
going to be true
and you know he's looking oh yeah i'm
never hush
but i didn't kill that one he said i was
going to kill her
he said i came back to kill her
but she was gone i couldn't find it then
i said when sam could have took
credit for one did not and um
and so they told me he's not out there
just just trying to get numbers he's out
there wanting to talk about his cases
now we get a sense of his killings but
what drove
sam little did choking with these women
happen before
the sex or during or right afterwards
when did it mostly happen
i choose i picked i choose her out first
you pick the ones that you think you're
going to kill
nurse no if you want the benzo higher
than that
so clearly a lot more to talk about and
in part two of our sam little story
we're going to get into his background
in psychology
why he stopped killing and also whether
little
is responsible for more murders than we
know about
so that's all we have for you right now
on prime crime but leave us your
comments and instagram and twitter with
the hashtag primecrime
as always thank you for joining us and
until next time
be safe
[Music]
you